[Music]
we are going to talk about Joaquin
Phoenix as the new Joker we're going to
talk about some dorks at Yale that made
robot skin but first check out this
video this is of a two-headed snake it
comes to us from Virginia a woman found
this in her flower bed while she you do
some oh it's about that's a Viper
Copperhead kill it we have so many
problems in this country we do not need
this we're done with freaks here so much
going on if you just look at
Twitter we do not need this as well
genre movie where the thing is too big
and they have to kill it kill it
Godzilla
King Kong killer it's a copperhead it's
the kind that they kill with one head
kill it it's dangerous I don't think
it's dangerous but I looked at in the
eyes and I couldn't look away because
the snake because with two different
heads it wants two different things so
to one side is like it doesn't want to
be alive what's that is evil I mean
honestly maybe the other side is like
kill me definitely wants to die that
wants to die and I think that euthanasia
should be legal for human beings as well
pets am I not as good as my pet
let me die I don't think I should die
I'll only get to die and if somebody
should kill it I think it's just leave
it in nature let let nature take care of
itself you know to me like that's so
true think about all the other snakes
out there who want to have sex with a
two-headed dude yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
how snakes have sex it's actually kind
of cool they coil the coil around each
other both of them at the same time just
cuz they have two heads right I think
it's one creature with two heads yeah oh
do they Chevis all oh no kill it Wow I
want to shed the skin so to speak on
that robots in they created this for the
astronauts this is to help when they
encounter unexpected situations in space
so they can fix stuff show the next
video Gillian of course we're using this
to bring our stuff the animals the
[Applause]
[Laughter]
scariest on this is pretty cool I
think that the applications are gonna be
great but I think that application
terrify the guy to me it's like puppet
master meets like Chucky and it's like
weird there's a lot of scary movies and
it's so many things that it's just
nightmare
that just as an adult scared to shout at
me I don't know it's a scary day on
every damn day
like five dollars in the air put all
that on it that's cost like
thousands of dollars it makes it look
worse that's animals not expensive
enough and mine's just say it's a lot of
effort to make us shitty stuffed animal
this is an example because everyone
wants to go to goddamn all my clothes
are made of this material and that's
what's been keeping me moving for the
past four or five years you're an early
adopter yep so what happens if you turn
it off gracious enough to give me the
remote to his clothes just to like keep
him grounded that would be great if they
gave this what's it called micro skin
I'm the skinny skin if they give the
Omni skin to everybody on RuPaul's Drag
Race and just let them make a robot and
be like let's see the applications of
this thing I think that would be you can
control the models on the runway and
have them fight each other
[Applause]
we want to talk about one more thing
throw that up Jillian this is Joaquin
Phoenix as the Joker in the new Joker
origin movie the director Todd Phillips
shared this photo on his Instagram
he just captioned it Arthur which is a
nod to Arthur Fleck the Joker's pre
Joker name and then watch this video
this is the screen test Wow oh what's
going on flashing the light oh this is
over it he's not into it not into the
moving leg doll thing with wait keep it
I just don't find this I don't give
maybe I'm over the Joker's in time is
over I don't like it you wake up I think
we've ever had on the show what that
looks bad dad it look good it looked
boring
come on it look like it's like I don't
wanna watch an anthology about Joker the
Encyclopedia Britannica of Joker movie
did you watch the last one was it called
the the toon squad with because he seems
like such a dick in such a crazy person
where it's like Heath Ledger was so good
because he was like so well I mean you
know we all know what happened how undo
it he was but he makes like he's a
monster like everything I've heard about
him is like he's like a psychopath so I
think he's already there I think he's
gonna be very nervous because I agree
where I'm like this feels irresponsible
I'm like we've started something that we
now can't control
I'm Jared Leto tried to do this he sent
like his cast members like old fish and
all this kind of stuff he's kind of it
and gross like that
Oh Phoenix is keeping to himself and
just acting really well keeping
themselves
well we haven't heard any stories about
him sending condoms in the mail yeah I
wish Casey Affleck was playing
talk about dynamic duo ladies all right
I do have a youtube shoutout this comes
from astro ryan commenting about our
sketch show that dropped on friday this
is the episode where hannah dates a
Disney Channel star and he asked who
plays the Disney Channel kid though pop
caller Chazz doesn't need this and that
was our buddy Graham who was so good
remember how great Graham was day so
good he beat me up he threw a trash can
at me and he was fantastic so I hope
that we get him back very soon for
another episode I don't how many takes
do you think we did in that trash can
getting through we're gonna do them
dinner right
[Music]
sure the matrix is about how nothing is
real and we're living in a computer
simulation but isn't it also a movie
about how everyone looks good in black
[Music]
your Instagram comments should never
express your true feelings genuine
feedback makes people feel unsafe it's
actually kind of beautiful
once preferred porn once it opens is
announced it really why and then the and
then it feels good it's pleasurable
friction for the snakes and then they
these scoots back up and then a baby
snake comes out of the mouths of the
other you think that you think the holy
they're just scissoring
let's all go around what didn't they
like kind of like they back in and they
like like DNA like they have water
separate waves I think they do the thing
in that movie with Rachel McAdams and
ritualize where they just spit in each
other's mouths
it's obedient yeah all snakes are
lesbians yes and we think that's cool
see you next time on every day I'm day
[Music]